Unless you’ve been avoiding the internet
for a decade (and if so, welcome!)
You’ve probably heard about the bee rapture.
In 2006, the first instances of something
called colony collapse disorder were reported.
That winter, 25 percent of all bee colonies
in the US were destroyed.
That means billions of bees.
CCD is this strange phenomenon where worker
bees leave the colony never to return!
The queen, bee youngins, and all that honey
is just left behind.
CCD could devastate food production, as bee-pollination
accounts for 15-billion dollars a year in
crops.
No bees, no foods!
So, for at least a decade, scientists have
been working like a bee to try and solve CCD.
They've found at least 60 different environmental
factors...
Like a combination of invasive pests, climate
change and pesticide poisoning.
After all this research, a new report has
finally given us some good news.
The bees are making a comeback!
The USDA just released its latest honeybee
health survey, aaaand the number of honeybees
is on the rise!
There are now 2.89 million honeybee colonies,
a 3% increase from the previous year.
Also, the number of hives lost to Colony Collapse
disorder is down 27% from the previous year.
Victorious!
Right?
That said, there are still some major threats
to the hives, mainly two things: the pesky
varroa mite and pesticides.
The mite, also called the varroa destructor
(don't get excited it's bad) is the ultimate
honey bee pest.
These destructors are parasites that thrive
inside hives, sucking blood from the bees
while transmitting viruses directly into their
bloodstream.
They end up leaving the bees weakened, with
shorter lifespans, and in some cases with
deformed wings.
Honey bees are part of a collective.
They all work together and need each other
to keep the colony alive.
So, if a hive is mite infested to the point
of no return, it will eventually collapse.
By nature the varroa mite is not a migratory
pest, which we thought was good for bee-kind,
but now a new paper found it is able to hitchhike
on wandering bees and spread to new hives.
This is particularly problematic for commercial
beekeeping where beehives are kept in close
proximity because the varroa destructors ride
on the backs of weakened honey bees to neighboring
colonies and the infestation starts all over.
Varroa destructors were wreaking havoc in
42% of U.S. colonies between April and June
of 2017.
Which is down from last year's figures, but
still, isn’t quite where we want it to be.
The secondary enemy for the bee are pesticides,
particularly neonicotinoids.
This year, the USDA reported that pesticides
were responsible for 13% of total damage to
the bees.
Neonicotinoids, or neonics, are synthetic
chemical insecticides that are very similar
in molecular structure to nicotine; it’s
even got the word in it.
When a neonic is sprayed on crops, the chemicals
are absorbed in the plant's nectar and pollen.
This makes the flowers toxic to the bees who
swing by for lunch.
Countless studies have drawn a link between
neonics and neurological damage in bees.
It’s also reportedly affected their ability
to fly home, which may explain why worker
bees aren’t returning to their colonies,
hence the colony collapse.
So here's the buzz: the bees are bouncing
back but they need all the help they can get.
If you want to help the bees and happen to
be a gardener, avoid using outdoor insecticides
near flowers that bees might be attracted
to, or nurture some plants that could be future
pollination pit stops for our buzzy friends!
Just bee aware.
Bees are the best and I love them.
But they work so hard!
Do they sleep?
Julian has the answer here.
Are you worried about bees?
Bee fatigue if you will?
Tell us in the comments, please subscribe
and thanks for watching Bee-ker, er.
Seeker.